la capitale ukrainienne plongée dans le
noir alors que les températures
hivernales s'installe les habitants de
plusieurs villes d'Ukraine pennent à se
chauffer comme ici à Carson
des travailleurs humanitaires nous
apportent de l'eau potable mon fils aîné
m'apporte aussi de l'eau potable
sur les 300 000 habitants que comptait
la ville seul 80 000 sont restés le
président ukrainien a alerté le Conseil
de sécurité des Nations unies nous
rétablirons tout cela et nous
traverserons tout cela parce que nous
sommes en peuple incassable
depuis le mois d'octobre la Russie prend
régulièrement pour cible les
infrastructures énergétiques du pays des
frappes qui ont aussi privé
d'électricité plus de la moitié de la
Moldavie voisine
est gravement touchée par cette guerre
sur le plan de la sécurité énergétique
des requêtes et des missiles russes ont
traversé notre espace aérien nous sommes
à Paris pour travailler avec nos
partenaires européens afin d'atténuer
l'impact de cette guerre sur la Moldavie
pour faire face à la crise côté
ukrainien des centres d'invincibilité
vont être installés dans les villes les
plus touchées objectif fournir
gratuitement à la population électricité
chauffage eau et connexion Internet 24
heures sur 24